[Music]  [Music]  you don't even need to wear makeup  sorry what  i just said you don't even need to wear  makeup  all right  what was that  did you know anyone who died  [Music]  did you have like the craziest  nightmares last night you have to be  able to sleep to have nightmares  tell me about your brother he was  always making me laugh  what are you feeling right now i feel  mad  you went through something no one should  ever have to go through can you stay  just fall asleep let  it go five's [ __ ] hard i'm sorry  we're saying [ __ ] no you're right  life's [ __ ] hard god well try it it  feels good life's [ __ ]  confusing i can't [ __ ] feel anything  what are you thinking about i can't say  it let's say you die tomorrow and what  if you die sad because you regret not  saying what you wanted to say  [Music]  this can't be for nothing we won't even  let this be for nothing  [Music]  the shoulders you can't do it without  the  [Music]  like  shoulders  you